two stories popped up in the last couple
days that I thought were really
interesting
so first off the feds right now are
seeking prison time for 70-year-old
medical marijuana patient who is growing
weed on his personal property
in Washington the state Washington where
medical marijuana is legal
but they also fat they found at seventy
pop like they also did find some guns
be wasn't doing anything illegal per se
by the state laws but again this is the
bed
stepped in and did this because medical
marijuana is obviously
legal I federal level 'em
and I think this is really interesting
because to me
I was there with a bombing here because
I think he's had this both ways
he makes it seem like he's the cool hip
weed smoking president.
right we talked about we ought I mean
even said that two months ago that thing
about you know we'd is no worse than
you have a couple brings it up there yet
using charger
federal government if I know anything
about government and he is the one that
is still enforcing these laws
that are allowing the fed's the coming
because these places at
over IRS over start with a bomb and then
we'll go back or so so obviously as
president he can't personally
go through every that have the
government and make sure that they're
doing what he tells them to
I find this very surprising because Eric
Holder the Attorney General put out a
guidance
I was at six months ago year ago saying
that we are not going to focus on
individual users we're not gonna focus
on
you know the non-violent offenders we're
going to focus on people who are
obviously involved in crime and drug
trafficking
these people obviously not involved in
that so I think that there's an issue
right with the physically but with
attorney in Washington State writers the
100 percent against what Eric Holder
said by the way the
the guy who did this seven-year-old
medical marijuana patient is facing ten
years in prison as our
a some his relatives that lived on the
comment and a family friend
arm to is this just like the worst kind
government hypocrisy our
well you know I love the government so
much yeah you know telling you there no
I'm
first on the 10 years if not I don't get
normal there they added years because
he was founder be into the Treasury
firearms right
so you know I don't know who's that a
typical situation
on I do think this is one other things
whereas
as things change and as I you know the
sovereignty of states are recognized by
the federal government but I hope
he that that I'm as
you know nationwide mentality towards
this changes then it looks like it's
going in that direction
especially for somebody who just doing
it for medicinal purposes for providing
for people who have
seizures epilepsy cancer yeah I think it
will at national chains which is that
weird space before
we get to where we're going yet so the
medicinal part I want to get to in a sec
and
the what is the angle here I really like
this is one of those things where Obama
says one thing and does another
like a I just can't figure out what is
his what is the point what is he saying
the holder
what that they that they feel this is
are free
i doing it I think this is a conflict
between a US attorney
and that is actually defying orders from
they
the main office essentially I you know I
don't get the impression that Obama or
holder
think that this is a wise use of
resources red to white as a holder just
get on the phone ground that I don't
understand because you know he could get
on it they need to stop doing this is a
waste of resources they're going after
you know a 70-year-old man who
owned guns which is you know his right
under the second amendment
yeah because they were saying that he
was using those guns in the commission
of a crime because
federally having pot you know growing
weed on your property against law even
though it is not against the law in the
state right-o
it shouldn't be those things are not
even on the same I but they are in
conflict and there's a huge gray area
legal limbo so we know for the US
attorney to then served if I i think
there's something else going on with
this particular US attorney but I do not
know what that is because really it's
completely illogical friend to be doing
what he's doing
the ITU will get to the middle part a
sec but shouldn't the
republicans to me this seems like the
David thing where they were smart which
they're not we know that
if they were smart they be like this is
the type thing we should be fighting
words with it fighting for states rights
its fighting for individual liberty you
get a lot of sympathy
saying I want someone who is sick to be
able to do whatever it takes to
feel better a why don't they jump on
board
this thing I i think it would alienate
so much in their base
as far as the people who are the
generation who grew up with like
those crazy videos 1962 kids like
smoking we made it up and i five hundred
yeah I i'm
I think that the only reason I agree
with you mean like this as an
opportunity
for you to like be on the cutting edge
up like the future so why would you like
it and they could be taken
they could be taking the populace thing
and saying look what Obama is doing
that's why I don't get the Obama angle
and I don't get the
the Republic and I think it like I think
you're right I think it has to do with
the
preconceived notions from the base from
you know the or older generations who
are less likely to be open to the idea
medical marijuana or even recreational
marijuana other but let's be real like
my parents
sure smart way more me but I ever yeah
will have to go to college I didn't have
the right to right back and you know you
don't go to school the drug that has are
you can find a exactly know their
up